now what happens next nobody knows
there's a lot of different speculation
going on here about what's really going
on obviously this whole thing took place
after Tay to put out a tweet calling out
to Greta talking about please provide
your email address so I can send a
complete list of my car collection and
their respective enormous emissions and
as she responded back with you know the
small D energy and then they went back
and forth that thing got 570 000
retweets and then boom next thing you
know December 29 couple days after that
if not 24 hours after that uh he gets
arrested he and his brother get arrested
amongst the uh as well as the other two
girls